when I was a child the weather was still  nature it was out of reach I went as a  child to Iceland and I was convinced and  to some extent that was rised that I was  looking at landscape that no other  person had touched or been into a scene  before probably there was not quite the  case but I had the feeling I was on the  moon and there was this distinct idea  well this is culture and there's a line  and behind that line is nature not  touched by men and one of the last  things that I thought would be touched  was the air that I was breathing the  atmosphere and it turned out that as I  grew older I realized well that frontier  has now been not just pushed but it is  very there is no nature left everything  is to that extent culture and I realized  that even the ice blocks on the street  in Paris is religious culture its  culture the air and appealing is also  culture there is nothing left for us to  call inator which means we also have the  responsibility to nurture it  you